hello everyone
welcome to this interesting video on
python data visualization tutorial by
simply loan
data visualization is an essential part
of any data analysis process
it helps to discover hidden patterns and
insights from the data
so in this video we will learn how to
create impressive charts and graphs with
real-world data sets using python
libraries
our experienced instructors will help
you learn everything in detail
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply loan channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
us
now
let's have a look at the agenda for
today's video
so we will start by understanding the
matplotlib python library
so with matplotlib you will learn to
create static animated and interactive
visualizations in python
then we will look at the cbon library in
python
cbond library is based on matplotlib and
provides a high-level interface for
drawing attractive and informative
statistical graphs
finally we will understand how the
python bokeh library works
book a is an
interactive visualization library that
provides highly interactive graphs and
plots so let's get started
matplot library today we're going to
study the matplot library and the python
code so what's in it for you what is
matte plot library types of plots
plotting graphs and sub graphs adding a
graph inside a graph graph parameters
title label legend
line graphs line types color and
transparency canvas grid and axis range
2d plots scatter step bar fill between
radar chart histogram contour image 3d
surface image and then we'll hit a
practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library
map plot library is an open source
drawing library which supports rich
drawing types it is used to draw 2d and
3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the map flight
library that we can't even cover them
all today but we'll hit the main one so
you have a good understanding of what
the matplot library is and what the
basics can do you can understand your
data easily by visualizing it with the
help of matplot library you can generate
plots histograms bar charts and many
other charts with just a few lines of
code and here we have some basic types
of plots you can see here that we'll go
into we have the bar chart the histogram
boy i use a lot of histograms in my
stuff scatter plot line chart pie chart
and area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupyter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that and
you'll look at any of our tutorials i
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up jupiter and anaconda i
myself use jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look at this see what that
looks like you can see your anaconda
navigator if you install it it will
automatically install the jupiter
notebook but that also installed a lot
of other things i know some people like
the qt console for doing python or
spyder i've never used them i actually
use notepad plus plus as one of my
editors and then i use the jupiter
notebook a lot because it's so easy to
have a visual while i'm programming an
even simple script in python i'll take
it from the jupyter notebook and then do
a save as you can always go under file
and you can download as a python program
so that will download it as an actual
python versus the ipython that this
saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab and the version let's go
ahead and run this so we're going to
import our pi lab module from the
matplot library and we find out that
we're in version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're gonna graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np
now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us
and there is a lot of ways to create
data but we're going to use the np.line
space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers we're just going to divide that
equally up between 0 and 10. and if we
have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2. and let's just take a look we're
going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see we got going on here so we
have our x coordinates which is 0 0.4
0.83 etc and you can look at this as an
x y plot so we have zero we have two so
we have point four one six we have two
point one seven and just as a quick
reminder we're gonna do print np array x
comma y dot reshape 25 comma two and the
reason i want to do this is i want to
show you something here
a lot of times a program returns x comma
y and it's an array of x comma y x comma
y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pi
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it and
then for our basic plotting of this data
it only takes one command to draw graph
of this data and so we use our from up
here where we imported pi lab we take
our pi lab and the keynote under there
is plot for plotting a line and then we
want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay
so let's take our pi lab
and create a sub plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values and we're going to represent by
rows columns and indexes
and let's do one two one so it's going
to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to plot data onto the
subplot so the order is very important
and we're going to stick with our x
comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two and if
we're going to do that let's do another
one pi
lab.subplot and if we're going to do row
one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're gonna add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pi lab
subplot there we go by lab we got to go
ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot
there we go we'll move that down here
real quick because that goes in the plot
part so the subplot tells it the row
column and index and the pi plot tells
it what data in this case we switched
them and the color and then the style
shorthand now let's go ahead and run
that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's this
depreciated there's another way to do it
but most people just ignore that warning
because it's not going to go away
anytime soon now that's using the same
setup what happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as two and let's change the row
on the second one to two and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two i squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does there's all kinds of
different things you really have to just
play with these numbers till you get a
handle on them because
you know we have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three run
there we go but you can see it takes a
little bit sometimes to play with these
and get the numbers right hopefully hit
the wrong one that's why let's go three
there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fid we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize the
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas as pd and numpy
array is np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from 0 to 1.
and so we can go ahead and i'm just
going to put some stuff in there i got
0.5 0.1.8.8
so when you're looking at this this is a
zero to one or you could say fifty
percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're gonna use
eighty percent and we're gonna have like
a little indent on the left and the
right and this should look familiar from
above x's dot plot x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a axis instead of a x e s
i don't know where that came from but
this looks identical to the one we had
up above so here's our axis plot x comma
y of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
are canvas our axis is what we're
working in and then our axis dot plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we're going to
fig comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals two so if you
remember before that's what we did we
had one row with two different graphs on
it we're going to do the same thing but
know how we did this here's our figure
our canvas and our axes we're going to
create actually two different axes we're
going to create row 1 column 2. and so
axis is an array of information so we
can simply do
4
let's do x in axes
this is now look familiar x dot plot
we're going to do x comma y we'll go
ahead and make a red
keep everything looking the same
remember nice uniform graphs everything
looks the same and if we go ahead and
run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute eric's is
trying to scrunch everything together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture
or graph
inside another graph
that's kind of a fun thing to do it's
important to note that we can layer our
stuff on top of each other which makes
for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig we'll create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas we set that
equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axes
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axis is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure add axes and then 0.2
0.5.4.3
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axes1 dot plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red and then let's go
axes2 dot plot and let's reverse them y
comma x comma green there we go doing
what i told you not to do you shouldn't
be swapping axes around and plotting
your data in five different directions
because it's confusing let's go ahead
and run this and see what this looks
like and then let's talk a little bit
about this we talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2
0.5 is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one
that actually is they had it down at
left right i thought this was wrong it's
actually how far from the bottom let me
switch that on here bottom there we go
so we had here on this we can go ahead
and put that back to 0.5 and run that
and this is 0.3 let's make this 0.3 also
and that is the width and then of course
there's the height we can make that
really tiny actually let's do 0.2
let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 8.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by nine let me run
that and show you what that looks like
so it fills the whole screen and then if
you are normally when you're working on
the screen you don't worry too much
about this but we can set the dpi to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by nine and then the dpi is 300 on
here so it's a little higher quality and
just out of curiosity i wonder how long
it takes to draw something double that
size 600 and you can see here where at
600 dpi it's going to take a while there
it goes just because it's utilizing a
lot more graphics on there and let me
just go back to the 300 now we'll
actually do let's do a 100 you're not
going to see a difference on this
because it is web based graphics are
pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and then we
run that and of course we can also do
upper size a little bit you can see
what's going on a little better so here
we have x label x if you come down here
you'll see our x label and our y label
we can of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
would be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're gonna do
we're gonna set our ax legend label one
label two up here it's a format for it
but let's go down here and actually use
it i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we actually do axes
since we have the two plots legend and
on here we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
location one i can't remember where
that's at there we go upper right so
each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kinda have to play with them
or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title the graph looks a little
fuzzy so i might in a web setup put the
dpi up a couple notches maybe put it at
200 100 might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots dpi equals oh let's do
200 to see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure and our axes equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see and
let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axis dot plot
x x plus three this looks like we're
doing nearest neighbor setup we're
showing how it
located data putting your lines on there
between the nearest neighbors there we
go so it draws a nice little graph with
three lines on it one of the things we
can do is we can control the alpha on
this oops and you can actually see the
when they did these lines it
automatically pulls in different colors
for your setup so there's some automatic
automatic things going on in there and a
lot of times we do that comma r where
we're going to do color equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there
and with the matte plot library you're
not limited to red you can also use the
one of many different color references
as you see here with the pound sign one
one five five dd which just is just blue
and we can do the same thing with
another color on here which turns out to
be green i can just as easily do this
green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to say what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go and run that and
let's go back and look at this where it
crosses over and the first thing you see
right here is on the blue it's kind of
light blue now you can see how the two
colors add together you get almost a
purple on there so i can clearly see
where the red crosses the blue line and
then the green just blanks it over
because i didn't do any opaqueness no
alpha on there so this is great if you
have lots of data that crosses over and
you need to be able to track those lines
better and we'll go ahead and do this
0.5 and we'll run that oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as the
default is one solid so we can change
this all to point eight let me just do
that
oops 58 there we go
run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i actually
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at 80
instead of 50 percent when you can do
less that's kind of fun although at some
point the lines kind of fade
so 0.5 is usually the best setting on
there we have a nice pastel here at 0.3
and you can easily see where they cross
over and just like you can play with the
colors we can play with line width and
you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
do four of these lines just you can see
how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if i run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line
width
width
equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5
and let's do one let's make this equal
to 2. let's see what that looks like and
we do that you can see it goes from a
very thin line a 0.5 a 1 our 1.5 and 2
which is twice the width of the one and
if we're going to do different sizes we
had different colors we had our alpha
scheme let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything point two and let's set up
a line style we'll do the first one
dashes and let me just paste that down
here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot let's do the dash
dot here and a colon here there we go
and there's a lot of different options
we'll look at a few more as we go down
for different ways of highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything as a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus um
four so it goes right on the top and do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line
and we're going to take the line and
we're going to set dashes so look i've
changed some of the notation here for my
line and my ax plot so i can set my line
comma equal to x plot and then i can
change the line settings this way and
when i run this let me run that on here
you'll see the 5 10 15 10
creates a series of dashes
that are buried in link link in this
case they alternate between a short dash
and a long dash we can play with these
numbers curiosity always has me what
happens when you play with the numbers
just to see what they look like let's do
this let's paste this down here i'll do
two of these just because they're kind
of fun to play with and let's change
this from 10 to
three and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
four and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have dashes of
five let's see i'm going to guess this
is the dashes of five skip ten dashes of
15 skip three and then it goes back to
the beginning dash is five dashes skip
ten fifteen dashes skip three and of
course the last one we just switched up
a little bit it looks a lot more uniform
because i'm using two sets of ten or if
i did something like this and change it
to 30 it really becomes pronounced as
far as the distances between them and
instead of four let's go oh let's put 30
here also 30 by 30. there we go really
pronounced on that one and let's look at
one more important group for plotting
our data and in this we're gonna here's
our plot we started with with the x plus
one x plus two x plus three and did it
in blue on this one's three or four
different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a dot for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option
dots is most common i'll actually like
the dots the best if we do the plus sign
you can see it puts a nice crosshairs or
plus sign on there and we can do a
marker there's a number of different
markers you can use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one that's for square o
for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do marker
size equals two and change that to five
and run that and you can see here it's a
nice little tiny dot versus uh the size
dot here this is interesting because it
said two i thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we had marker size so we
also have marker face we'll set that
equal to red of course we i mean change
the so it's up one notch we'll run that
whoops must have mistyped something on
here and i did it's marker face color
equals red and so when i run that you
can now see i have the squares on there
with the marker face color of course we
can mix and match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge generally though you want something
a little bit smaller and cuter we'll
just try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face
so four you can start to see the face on
there around four and maybe an eight
eight might be a good number for this
there we go eight again that all just
depends on what you're trying to show
and display so we've covered a lot of
stuff here as far as our lines we've
covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line width different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a plus sign the
square a little tick which uses a one
then we had a marker size and a marker
color face and we combined those you see
we get a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on all those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have
one more piece to formatting the graph
so we want to show you and then we have
two big sections we're going to go over
the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're gonna do a figure size of 10 comma
5. this should all look familiar now
since we've done a number of them and
we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared x
x cubed line with two so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to true on here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
our two plots with the x value going
across
and i'm going to do
something similar and by the way as you
can just if you look at it you can see
the grid on there that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same
data for axes one so we have our plot of
x x squared x and x cubed line with two
and this time we're going to take our
axes one and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma 60 i'm just making these numbers
up the guys in the back actually made
them up i'm just using their numbers
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as
don't forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to sixty so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit two
to five so that starts right here at two
and you can see very different graphs
this is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph remember how we did that
earlier one inside the other but just a
quick note you can easily limit your
graph and re kind of reshape the way it
looks quite easily and we can also add
that grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if i'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at four common
graphs we'll put them side by side so
we'll do a figure our axes equals plot
subplots one four columns and then
figure size hopefully it'll fit nicely
on here it seems to do a pretty good on
here and i'll go and just run that since
we're in there run you'll see i have no
four blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of
zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
n or we can do x or n there we go and
let's go ahead and do axes set title
scatter i've already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are have a lot of
random numbers connected to them that's
why they do them on there and so the
bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
exes one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that end value
up here and so for this we have n
n times 2 our n squared n times 2 n
squared line width equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run
and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i've used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very uh concrete
objects somebody how many people wearing
yellow hats that kind of thing but if
we're going to do that let's go ahead
and do the last one which i see a lot
more in the sciences certainly using the
data science but more like for mapping i
saw publication on uh solar flares and
they were discussing the energy and so
filling in the graph gives it a very
different look so we're going to do the
fill between and it's just like you
think it'd be it's filled between but
with a underscore between them and we'll
do x and x squared and x and x cubed and
we'll do color green and alpha again in
case you had other data you want to plot
on there you can see it forms a nice
squared coming up here and also if you
look at the bottom one is your squared
value the upper line is your cubed value
and then it fills in everything in
between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor and
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i can't find
a reason to use one now so the first
line for doing a radar chart we have to
add axes and the figure and with this
this actually creates our oh let's let's
run it so you can see what it creates it
creates a nice looks like you're on a
submarine and you're tracking the hunt
for red october or something like that
and it needs all of these the polar is
the fact that we're doing polar
coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box
if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had point six on here i'll go ahead
and leave it as one because that's just
kind of fun that's all about the size on
here the height and the width and then
let's create some data t equals np line
space and this is 0 to 2 times np times
pi so if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate a 100 points
so this is just a thing of data we're
putting together then we simply do an ax
dot plot and in this case let's do t
comma t which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart and we'll give it a
nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we can do t times two
spirals out a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun i've like i said i've
never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much and we'll use
our numpy that we have set as np to
generate oh looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes from subplots 1 2
figure size 12 14. so we're going to
look at two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data 1000 random arrays it looks like
they're mostly between -4 and 4 and then
it adds up each one it says 0 you have
35 000 that are zero so that's what's
most common on here and we have 20 000
that are somewhere in this range right
here between the minus two and well it
looks like one and minus two and
somewhere between zero and one there's
thirty thousand numbers so all this is
saying is this is how common these
variables are and this gives you this
point in so many directions when you're
looking at data science to go ahead and
run your histogram so you should always
have your histogram and you can always
put limits and all the other different
things on your array just like you did
on the other graphs on there and then
we're going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has the prints of data out
for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go it
doesn't help that i put it over the old
one there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for five
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different luck
wait it shifts it all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's a
cumulative detail the histogram of the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
and we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're gonna our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x and we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our x y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z of one minus z2 times two
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z
if you remember x y we created as our x
and y components using our mesh grid and
you know what let's do this just because
it's kind of good to see this let's go
ahead and print
x and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
those are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y be in the coordinates while z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represents zero maybe that's sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then -1 and
different setups little hills i guess if
it's minus that's like a pit so i guess
you're going down into a pit at minus
five and minus one but on the other side
you can see you're going up in levels so
here's a mountaintop and here's like a
basin of some kind and in data science
this could represent a lot of things
this could also be representing two
different values and maybe profits and
loss i don't know if i'd ever really do
that as a contour map but i'm sure you
can be creative and find something fun
to do with a contour map and then we're
going to look at one last map which is
the 3d map and those are can be really
important as a final product because
they can show so much additional
information that you can't fit on
two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image
and so we're going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14
by six that's a good fit on the screen
we'll go ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since this also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y
capital z so there's our data coming in
and we're going to add some settings in
here we're going to do r stride 4 c
stride 4 and line with 0. i'll show you
what that is here in just a minute let's
go ahead and run that so we can see our
graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these i'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to one
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead and you're
gonna see how it starts reshaping the
size and how it fits on the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size now fits
on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what we're talking about here this is
column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole set up on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into
let me go back up here here we go this
one has different colors for the
different values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image into nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type markdown and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a python program
to create a pie chart of the popularity
of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our matplot library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c-sharp c
plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2
java 17.6 and i don't know if these are
real numbers they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know if
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used
exclusively for data science is r
so python's big and python also does a
lot more it's a full programming
language where r is primarily for data
science they didn't put r in here so we
have python we have java we have our php
and you can see the different values
they've given it or different
percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi
and we're plotting
popularity there we go
and before we add in all the really cool
settings for this let's go ahead and run
it and you'll see we generate a nice
flat pie not too exciting there and then
we'll go ahead and put in all the extras
i talked about explode we can explode
one of the values out so here's our
explode equals explode labels as
languages because we want to know what
the different colors mean here's our
colors equals colors our auto picture
and this is standard print format so
that's a python set up on there and
that's just going to put the value on
the pie slice and then we're going to
add shadow because it just looks cooler
with a shadow gives a little 3d look and
we'll do a start angle of 140. let's go
ahead and run this and take a look and
see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
that's pushed out there's our shadow a
3d effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
90
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pi slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run it'll
default to zero this is what it looks
like if it defaulted to zero so
depending on where you want the
highlighted slice to appear usually you
want that appear on the left because
people read left to right and so it
draws a focus onto in this case python
and how great python is i'm a little
biased we're teaching a python tutorial
so it should be understandable that
we're looking at python and one last
reference before we close you can go
over to the matplot library dot pi plot
set up and if you go underneath there
the different functions on there you can
look this up on their website you'll see
a full list and this is why it's so
important to go through a tutorial like
this because this list is just so
massive trying to figure out like here's
our bar plot there's a bar h you can add
barbs there's a box plot we didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here h i s t
there's also the his 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive
we've covered all the basic ones so that
you know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your map plot library
c-bond library in python
we will learn how to visualize data and
draw insights with different charts and
graphs using the c bond library
these visualizations are often referred
to as plots in python
so what is c bond in python the c bond
library in python is a widely popular
data visualization library that is
commonly used for data science and
machine learning tasks
it is built on top of the matplotlib
data visualization library
and allows you to perform exploratory
data analysis
using cbon you can create interactive
plots to answer specific questions about
your data
it helps you find trends in your data
that you can't notice just by looking at
the data
now to understand the c-bond library in
detail and how to create different plots
and know the data better we'll be using
two data sets in our demo
the first one is the empty cache data
set and the second is the popular iris
flower data set
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and start with our
demonstration
so i am on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and
rename the notebook i'll say
cbon
demo
we'll rename it
all right
you can see i have
the first two cells already filled in
so while working on an exploratory data
analysis project using python you will
need numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon
libraries for data manipulation and
visualization
so let's import these libraries first so
i've already written import numpy as np
pandas pd matplotlib.pi plot as plt c
bond sns
all right so i'll hit shift enter to run
this
first cell
alright
now using the read underscore csv
function that is present in the
pandas library i am importing my data
set that is empty cars i'll tell you
what empty cars is about this is a csv
data set and here i have given the
location where my data set is present
let's run it
all right
now
let me go ahead and print the first
five rows
of my empty cars
data frame
for that i'm using the head function
if i run it
okay you can see here
it has given me the first five rows the
index starts from zero till four so
total five rows of information
and
you can see these are the columns that
are present in the empty cast data set
the first is the
model of the car now just let me give
you a background about this data set
so the data is taken from the 1974
motor trend us magazine
it has information about fuel
consumption and 11 different aspects of
automobile design and performance of 32
cars
all right
so here we have the first column as the
model of the car and then we have mpg
which is
miles per
gallon
then we have cyl which stands for the
number of cylinders in the vehicle or
the car
then we have disp which is displacement
in
cubic inches so these all values are in
cubic inches
after that we have hp which is cross
horse power
then we have something called as
dr80 which is basically the rear axle
ratio
then we have wt which is the weight of
the
car in pounds
so think of it as
weight multiplied by
thousand pounds
all right and then we have q sec which
is 1 4 mile time this is a measure for
acceleration
then we have something called as vs this
is
the type of
engine for each of the vehicles so 0
stands for
v shaped engine and 1 stands for
straight engine
then we have am which is basically
the mode of transmission so
zero is for automatic transmission and
one is for manual transmission
then we have the number of
forward gears present in the vehicle and
then we have something called as carb or
carb
this stands for the number of
carburetors so carburetors is a device
for supplying a spark ignition engine
with a mixture of fuel and air
all right
now
we'll use the info function to print the
summary of the data frame so the info
function returns information regarding
the index data type column data types
then we
have the information about normal values
and memory usage
so i'll write my data frame name which
is empty cars
dot i'm going to use the info function
let's run it
and here you can see we have
all the columns
there are total 32
entries from 0 to 31 so
data about 32
cars
then here you can see the date types
and the memory usage
now moving ahead
let me
just print the
shape of the data frame that will give
you the number of rows and columns
present
i'll use the shape attribute
you can see here there are total
32 rows and 12 columns in my data set
now the c bond library provides a range
of plotting functions that makes the
visualization and analysis of data
easier
so we'll cover some of the crucial plots
that are available in cbon
so let's start with a bar plot
i'll give a
comment as
bar plot
now
first understand what a bar plot is so a
bar plot gives an estimate of the
central tendency of a numeric variable
with the height of each rectangle
it provides some indication of the
uncertainty around the estimate using
error bars
now to build this plot you usually
choose a categorical column in the
x-axis and a numeric column on the
y-axis
so
we'll create a bar plot between the
number of cylinders and the miles per
gallon
so let's start
i'll
declare a variable called res which
essentially stands for result
then i'll use sns
which is for the cbon library
i'll say sns dot
followed by my bar plot function
and inside the function
i'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
and then
for x axis within the bracket
using quotation i'll give my column name
as cylinder so this is going to be my
x-axis
and for y-axis i'll say
my data frame name empty cars
then the square bracket followed by my
y-axis column that is miles per gallon
now to display i'm going to use the
matplotlib function i'll say plt dot
show
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go
so here you can see on the
x axis we have the number of cylinders
so in our data we have
vehicles with
4 6 or 8 cylinders
and on the y axis you can see the miles
per gallon
now what essentially this graph tells us
is that
when the number of cylinders in the
vehicle increases my miles per gallon on
mpg for the vehicles decreases
and you can see these
black lines
so these lines
indicate
the uncertainty around
the estimate using error bars
all right
now you can create the
same bar plot using another way
now we will exclusively define the x and
y axis columns and also pass the name of
the data frame using the
data argument
let me show you how to do it
i'll use the same variable name res
which stands for result i'll say sns dot
bar plot
now inside the
bar plot function
i'm going to exclusively define my x
axis i'll say x equal to
i'll pass in my column as
cylinder
then i'll say y-axis
which is miles per gallon
and then using the data attribute
i'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars
and finally we'll write plt dot show
let me run it
you see here we have the exact
same bar plot
as the above one so this is another way
to create a bar plot now python c bond
allows the users to assign colors to the
bars
so the bar chart that we are going to
create will convert all the bars to a
particular color
so for that i am going to use the color
argument
so i will say res equal to
sns dot my function that is bar plot
i'll say x
equal to
cylinder
my y axis
we'll have
mpg
and then i'll say data
is empty cars
give a comma and my final attribute i'll
say
color
equal to i'll say yellow
close the bracket
and then
i'm going to write plt dot show
if i run it you can see here
all the bars have been converted to
yellow color now
you can change the
color
argument let's say i'll make it to red
if i print it you can see here all the
bars have been changed to red color now
all right
now c bond library also has the
palette argument
which you can use to give different
colors to the bars
so if you go to
google and search for
seaborn palette
you have a nice link here
so here you have there are different
palettes provided by
c bond you can see here sns dot color
palette
and these are the
names of the palette you can use
whichever palette you want
all right
so
i'll say res
equal to
sns dot
bar plot
we'll use our
first method of
assigning
a bar plot so i'm using my data frame
empty cars and this time we are going to
change the x and y labels let's say i am
using
my x label as
transmission whether
automatic or manual transmission
and then in my y-axis i'll have
miles per gallon
then
i'm going to say
palette
equal to
i made a spelling mistake here
let's say our palette is
set to this is the name of the palette
i'll write plt dot show
if i run it you can see
here we have the
two modes of transmission zero is for
automatic transmission of the vehicle
one is for manual transmission
and you can see the miles per gallon for
each of the modes of transmission if you
want you can change the palette colors
let me just copy this
i'll paste it in my new cell
and instead of set to let's say we'll
use
another pallet
called as rocket
and i'm also going to alter
my x and y labels let's say in my x
label i'll have
gear
and my label will be horse bar
if i run it
you see here we now have a different
palette and the bars are of different
colors on the x axis you have the gears
three gear four gear or five gear
vehicle
and on the
y axis you have the horse bar
so from the graph you can see
the horsepower is low for vehicles that
have four gears
while it is high
for the vehicles that have five gears
now let's understand how to create a
count plot
so the count plot function in the python
c-bond library returns the count of
total values for each category using
bars we will create a count plot that
returns the total number of vehicles for
each category of cylinders
i'll just give a comment here as
count plot
all right
so i'll start
sns dot
i'll use the count plot function
and i'll define my x axis as
cylinders
my y axis
won't have any label or any column
because y axis will only show the
count
then i'm going to
use my
data parameter or the argument and pass
in my data frame name that is empty cars
let's say i'll set the
palette
to
set one
let me run it
okay there is some error let's
debug the error
says str
object has no attribute get
okay so this should be
without the single quotes
make sure the data frame name is without
the
single quotes let's run it again
there you go
so you can see here this is a nice count
plot that
shows the number of cylinders on the
x-axis and on the y-axis you have the
count you can see here
there are more number of vehicles that
have eight cylinders and there are
less number of vehicles or cars that
have six cylinders
and actually you can count it as well so
you can see here there are 14 cars that
have eight cylinders there are
11 cars that have four cylinders and
there are seven cars that have
six cylinders
all right
now moving ahead
the next count plot will show the number
of cars for each carburetor
so for that i'm going to say
sns dot
count plot
my x-axis will now have
the variable
carburetor
i'll see data equal to empty cars
and
my palette
i'll set it to
set one
let's say set two now let me run it
you can see it here
on the x-axis we have the different
number of carburetors one two three four
six and eight
and you can see we have
more number of cars that have two and
four carburetors
and there are very few vehicles that
have
six and eight carburetor
cool now moving ahead
so the python c-bond library allows you
to create horizontal count plots where
the feature column is on the y-axis and
the count is on the x-axis let me show
you how to create a horizontal count
plot
i'll say sns dot
count plot
i'm going to define my
y label or the y axis as
gear
i'll say data equal to
empty cars
and
set my
palette to
let's say rocket
let me run it
okay you see here this is a
horizontal count plot if you compare it
with the above one these were all
vertical
count plot as in the bars were
vertically aligned but here you can see
the bars are all horizontally aligned
and
on the y axis you have the gear column
and on the x-axis you have the count
so if you mark here properly you can see
there are 15 vehicles with three gears
there are
12 vehicles that have four gears and
there are total five vehicles with five
gear
now you can also create a grouped count
plot using the hue parameter
so the hue parameter accepts the column
name for
color encoding
now let's
build
a count plot that shows the number of
cars for each category of gears grouped
by
the number of cylinders
so we are going to group based on the
number of cylinders let me show you how
to use the hue parameter for that
i'll say
sns.count plot
in the x axis i'll have my
gear column
then i am going to pass my hue parameter
that will have the
cylinder column or the number of
cylinders for each vehicle
i'll pass my data frame
using the data
argument
as empty cars and say pallet
i'll set my pallet to set one
let's run it
if i scroll down you see here we have
account plot on the x axis you have
three four and five gears of the
different vehicles
and
for each gear you have the
bars
that represent the number of cylinders
so for
vehicles that have three gears we have
majority of the vehicles having eight
cylinders
similarly for
vehicles that have four gears we have
most of the vehicles with four cylinders
and if you compare for the
cars that have five
gears
so we have equal number of vehicles that
have
four and eight cylinders and then
we have one vehicle that has
six cylinders
cool now moving ahead
so the c-bond library supports the
dist plot function that creates the
distribution of any continuous data
let's create the distribution of miles
per gallon of the different vehicles or
the cars
the mpg matrix measures the total
distance the car can travel per gallon
of fuel so here i'll give
a comment as dist plot which stands for
distribution plot
i'll say sns dot
dist plot
i'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
give a period and say
mpg which is my column name
then i'm going to
define the number of bins that i want
let's say 10
and then i'll use the
color argument
and i'll say let's say g which is for
green
let's run it now
there you go
if i scroll down you can see we have a
nice
distribution plot
so these are all histograms and
you can see we have a smooth curve
and this shows the distribution of
miles per gallon that is present in our
data set all right
now moving ahead
you can also create heat maps using the
c bond library
so the heat maps will let you visualize
matrix like data
the values of the variables are
contained in a matrix and are
represented as colors
you can create a correlation heat map
which is a graphical representation of a
correlation matrix representing the
correlation between different variables
so in our example we will create a heat
map where you can find the correlation
between each variable in the empty cars
data set
just give a comment as heat map
i'll say sns
and
i'll use the heat map function
i'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars followed by
my function called
corr which is for correlation
then i'll say c bar
is equal to true
so the
c bar argument is used to draw the color
bar then i'll say
line bits
i'll
pass it as 0.5
let's run it
there you go
here you can see we have a nice heat map
and on the right side you can see the
color bar that starts from
minus point eight and goes up to plus
point eight so this ranges between
minus one and plus one
and
the bars or the
cube you can see that have
a lighter color
have a positive correlation
and the ones that are dark have a
negative correlation
so for example
you can see here
for cylinder and mpg
the color is really dark which is around
this region minus 0.8 this means
when the number of cylinders in the car
increases your miles per gallon
decreases
and this
we also
had seen in our first
bar plot this one
you can see here whenever
the number of
cylinders increased your miles per
gallon had decreased
and this is what
has been depicted
in our correlation map or the heat map
but if you see for
cylinder and displacement there is a
positive
correlation which comes around this
color bar range
similarly there are other features in
the data set for example if you compare
for the weight of the vehicle and
the number of cylinders
there is a positive correlation which
means when the
weight of the vehicle increases the
number of cylinders present in the
vehicle also increases
and the others you can also compare and
find out the correlation based on this
color bar choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit scale up
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
okay now let's move ahead
the c bond scatter plot function helps
you create plots that can draw
relationships between two continuous
variables
so to understand about scatter plots and
other plotting functions
henceforth we are going to use
iris flat data set so let's go ahead and
load the iris flat data set i'll say
irish
equal to
sns dot
load underscore
data set
so this iris floor data set is already
inbuilt into the sns or the c bond
library
now we'll go ahead and
print the first five rows
from the data set
there you go
here you can see here
there are total
four feature variables you have the
sample length
supple width better length and petal
width of the
three species of flower
that is satosa
virginica and versicolor
so using this data set we are going to
see the rest of the c bond plotting
functions first let me go ahead and
print the different species of flower
and the
count for each of the species of flowers
that we have in our data set
i'll say irish
within square brackets i'll pass in the
output or the target variable that is
pcs and i'll use the function that is
value underscore counts
let's run it
there you go so we have
50 flowers of satosa type
again 50 flowers of versicolor species
and then
we have another 50 flowers of type
virginica so there are total 150 flowers
present in our data set
all right
i will create a scatter plot to show the
relationship between sepal length and
petal length for different species of
iris flask
so i'll say sns
dot
followed by the
scatter plot function in the x axis i'll
say
sample length
column
give a comma
i'll pass in my
y-axis with
petal length
then i'll say
data
equal to
iris
now let's run it
you can see
here this is my
scatter plot between
sepal length and petal length
now
you can classify the different species
of flowers using the hue parameter as
species in the function
so what i'll do is
i'm going to copy my
above
code i'll just paste it here
and we are going to edit in this cell
itself
i'll add a last parameter called hue
and this will have my species column
let's run it and see the difference
there you go
here you can see
we have a nice scatter plot
the blue dots are for satosha
the orange dots are for
versicolor and for virginica you have
the green dots
from this scatter plot you can see that
for virginia flowers the supple length
and the petal length are higher than
your versicolor and
satosa
and this region is completely
for satoshi flash
so you can see that the satosha flowers
have
lower sample length and petal length
all right
you can also
use another
parameter known as the size
that will
differentiate
the different pieces of flower in terms
of the size of the dots
i'll say size as species
let's run it you can see the result
there you go
so here you can see the
virginica
flowers are in green dots
the size is small
followed by versicolor with medium sized
dots and then
we have satosa
whose size is
large okay
now the python c-bond library lets you
visualize data using pair plots that
produces a matrix of relationship
between each variable in the data set
so let me show you how to create a pair
plot i'll say sns dot
peer plot which is the function
then i'll pass in my data frame name
that is iris
i'll put this
iris data frame within
double quotes
and we'll run it
okay there is some error here let's
debug the error
data must be panned as data frame okay
what i'll do is i'll just
remove
the double quotes and we'll run it
this might take some time to create the
pair plot so
just wait for a while
there you go
here you can see we have a nice pair
plot
on the
y axis you have the
supple length supple width petal length
and petal width similarly on the x-axis
also you have the
same
feature columns
all the diagonal plots are histograms
and the rest of the plots are
scatter plots
now you can convert the diagonal visuals
to
kde or kernel density estimation plots
and the rest of the scatter plots using
the hue parameter
this makes the pair plot easier to
classify each type of flower
so
i'll just copy this
cell of code
paste it here
and
i'll say hue
equal to
species then
i'll say
palette
equal to
set one
let's run it and we'll
see the new pair plot now
this might take some time
there you go
so here you have the
pair plot ready
and on the
right side you can see the different
species the red color dots represent
satosa
the blue color dots represent versicolor
and
the
green color
dots represent virginica flowers
now if you
look at this graph
you will find that
your petal length is the best feature to
classify the three different species of
flowers
the reason being you can see here
they are very well
categorized and they are separated
all the red dots present here in the
petal length represents satosa flash
around this range
all the blue dots represent
versicolor flowers and the green dots
are all
virginica flowers so out of the four
features petal width petal length sepal
width and
supple length
you can take
petal length as the
best feature to
differentiate between the three species
of flowers
all right
now
coming to lm plot function
so the
lm plot function in the
c bond library draws a linear
relationship as determined through
regression for continuous variables
so let's create the plot to show the
relationship between petal length and
petal width of the different species of
iris flowers
i'll just give a comment here as
lm plot
i'll say sns dot
lm plot
in the x axis we'll have
petal length
give a comma
in the y axis
i'll pass in
petal width
and i'll pass in my data frame using the
data argument or parameter which is iris
let's run
it you can see it here
we have a nice
plot
the line you see here
is a linear regression line
now in this
lm plot you can use the hue parameter to
differentiate between each species of
flowers and you can set
markers
for different
species let me show you how to do it
i'll say sns dot lm plot
we will say x
as our
petal length
give a comma
i'll write y
as
petal
width
then i'm going to pass the hue parameter
in here i'll see
my column as pcs
then i'll give data equal to
my data set name that is iris
and now you can pass in
markers
argument to differentiate the different
types of flaws
let's say i want to represent setosa
with
dot or o
then my next species which is
versicolor should be represented with a
star symbol
and the final
virginica species of flowers should be
represented with let's say
this arrow mark
now let me go ahead and run it
there you go
you have three different
linear regression lines
and
the circle dots in blue color represent
satosha
the orange color stars represent
versicolor flowers and
the triangles represent virginica
flowers so this is how you create
a linear relationship between the
different
types of flaws using the regression line
all right
now let's
take a look at the final plotting
function where we will create a box plot
a box plot also known as a box and
whisker plot depicts the distribution of
quantitative data
the box represents the quartiles of the
data set
the whiskers so the rest of the
distribution except for the outliers
now let's see the distribution of the
three species of flowers
based on their sepal width
i just give a comment as box plot
is the final plot that we are going to
see in our c bond
demo
i'll say s n s dot box plot
in the x axis we'll have the species
column
in the y axis we'll have
supple
width
then i'll pass my
data
as iris
let's run it
there you go
we have this
box plot created
at the bottom in the x axis you can see
we have
the box plot for
satosa flowers
orange for
versicolor flowers and green for
virginica flowers
now this line represents
median which is inside the box
so this is also the median for
versicolor flash you can compare the
median
sample width for each of the flowers
from the y axis
this line represents the
maximum
supple width value for satosa flower
and
this line at the bottom represents the
minimum
length of the supple bit for satosa
flowers
now these dots that you see outside the
box plot are called as outliers
the extended lines that are outside the
box plot are known as whiskers
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
cbon
library in python so first we
imported our empty car data set
then we saw how to create a bar plot
we learned how to use the color argument
or the parameter inside
bar plot
we also
saw how to use the palette attribute or
the palette parameter
then we learnt about
creating count plots
then we saw how to create horizontal
count plot
now moving ahead
we saw how to create distribution plot
then we saw
correlation heat map
after that
we analyzed the other functions
such as the scatter plot
then we had the pair plot
and we had the
lm plot for
finding the linear relationship and
later we saw the
box plot using the iris flower dataset
python bokeh we will teach you
everything that you need to know about
the bokeh library in python which is
used for data visualization
so
let's get started
before we dive into this video let's get
a basic overview of what you can expect
to learn from this video what's in it
for you
so first we will explain what exactly
the meaning of bokeh is
then we will take a look at scatter
charts and see how we can implement them
in bokeh
next we will understand what line charts
are the scenarios in which they are used
and how they can be coded in python
bokeh
then we'll move on to pie charts and
understand how data distribution can be
represented using them
next we will take a look at histograms
then we'll move on to bar plot and
understand the difference between
histograms and bar plots
we'll then take a look at area plot and
how to understand them
and then we will move on to the layout
function in bokeh which is used to make
interactive web pages
and finally we will use a data set to
understand how we can make interactive
charts in bokeh by using everything that
we've already learned in this video
so the first question that probably
comes to your mind is what exactly is
bokeh
bokeh is a python library which is used
to make highly interactive graphs and
visualizations
this is done in bokeh using html and
javascript
this makes bokeh a powerful tool for
creating projects custom charts and web
design based applications
now bokeh is a python library for
creating interactive visualizations for
modern web browsers
it helps you build beautiful graphics
ranging from simple plots to complex
dashboards with streaming data sets
with bokeh you can create javascript
power visualizations without writing any
javascript yourself
this makes it a very powerful tool for
data visualization
next let's take a look at scatter charts
and how you can plot them in bokeh
now scatter plots are a plot of each
individual data point in the data two
variables are plotted against one
another and each data point on the
x-axis has a corresponding individually
plotted value on the y-axis
as a result the plot looks like a bunch
of scattered points
these are some examples of scatter
charts
here each point on the chart corresponds
to a value on the x axis and its
respective value on the y y-axis
using scatter plots we can see how two
different variables correspond to each
other
now let's see how we can plot scatter
charts using bokeh
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of the
necessary modules for our python project
the first module that we're going to
need is the pandas module which is used
to work on data frames
next we will also be importing the
pandas bokeh module which is used to
implement bokeh on pandas data frames
next we will import bokeh.io which we
will use to show the various graphs that
we are plotting
we will also import bokeh dot plotting
which will help us in plotting all of
the various graphs that we're going to
be looking at
we'll also import glob a module which
will help us
merge our files and get them in the
required format
so the first line of code that we're
going to be writing is pandas underscore
bokeh dot output underscore notebook
this is basically just a line of code
which will help you see your output in
the same notebook itself
now let's see how we can plot scatter
plots in bokeh
we already have imported the figure
function from bokeh.plotting
the figure function contains most of the
plots that we want to plot such as line
plots scatter plots bar charts etc so
this is what we're going to be using
the first thing that you're going to
need to do is create a figure
so how do we do that
let's create a random variable p and
this we're going to be initializing to
the figure function
now within this figure function we're
just going to add a couple of
parameters for our figure itself so
let's say we want the plot width
to be equal to 400
and the plot
height to be equal to 402 we're going to
be plotting a scatter plot in the form
of a square here next we know that a
scatter plot is nothing but various
circles which are plotted on top of our
graph
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna be plotting
circles
at certain coordinates
which are going to be given by our lists
so the first coordinate is going to be
the x-axis and the next list that you're
passing in is going to represent the
y-axis coordinates so over here let's
just plot
this as one comma two
three
four and five
and over here let's start with four
seven
these are just random points this is
just to show you how exactly you can
plot a graph in bouquet
and now let's just say that we want the
size of the circles to be equal to 10
and the color of every
circle to be navy
we're also going to give a random
parameter called alpha and equate that
to 0.5 this will just act as a
placeholder
now over here you've initialized your
figure function and given in certain
parameters
and using this figure function you're
calling the circle attribute of it
passing in other parameters such as the
x-axis coordinates and the y-axis
coordinates the size of the circle the
color of each circle and a random
parameter called alpha so now we've
imported all of our modules
and this is how you plot a scatter chart
in bokeh
the same thing can be done when you look
at the line plot
all you have to do is initialize your
figure function
and call the line attribute of it pass
in your x-axis coordinates in your
y-axis coordinates
maybe pass in a couple of other
parameters that are required such as the
width that you want the line to be and
the color that you want the line to be
and finally all you have to do is show
the plot this is a basic overview of how
you can use bokeh to plot graphs
and here we have a line plot
so the main difference between the
scatter plot here and the line plot here
is that the line plot has various
different
points which are connected to each other
with the help of a line
so again what exactly are line charts
a line chart is a chart that represents
data as a series of points which are
connected to each other with the help of
a line
it is used to see trends in our data and
drag the way data changes over a period
of time
so this is the same chart that we just
plotted using bokeh right now so as you
can see
so the parameters that you know were
passed in were one two three four and 5
on the x axis
and 3 1 2
6 and 5 on the y axis
so how exactly the line chart is plotted
is that you plot each of these points
and then you connect them or join them
using a line
next let's take a look at pie charts and
how they can be implemented in bokeh
but first what exactly is a pie chart
a pie chart is a circular chart which is
divided into slices to represent how
much of the data belongs to a certain
category
it is a quick and easy way to see the
categories in our data and the
percentage of the data set that they
represent
on the other hand you have another type
of chart called a donut chart
donut charts are like pie charts with a
hole in the center and in this hole you
can use it to represent extra data
or you can draw a pie chart within that
hole itself
so this is an example of a pie chart
using this you can easily get to know
the various categories that our data is
divided into and the percentage that
each of these categories contribute
towards our data
like over here we have a pie chart which
represents crewmates and imposters in a
game called among us
so using this we can just say that
around 75 percent
of our
data is crewmates and 25 of it is
imposters
on the other hand you have a donut chart
which is almost exactly the same as the
pie chart except the middle portion is
missing values
and in this middle portion you can do
other things such as plot a pie chart
or represent other data within it so now
let's see how we can plot our pi plots
using python bokeh
but first we need to import the data
that we're gonna be using to plot all of
this
so the data that we're gonna be looking
at is the among us data
among us as you might know is a game
that caused quite a frenzy in the past
two years
so the data that we're going to be
working at is the among us data set that
you can find on kaggle
among us was the new craze for people
playing mobile games that suddenly
exploded in popularity and became a hit
video game during the pandemic
now among us is basically a multiplayer
game where 4 to 10 players are dropped
in an alien spaceship
each player has their own role of
imposter or crewmate
the task of the crewmate is to run
around the spaceship to complete various
tasks which are assigned to them and
also to not get killed by an imposter
players can be voted off the ship so
each game becomes one of survival
so let's load this data set and create
more features
so now we've imported our data set as
you can see our data set has over 2000
rows and 14 columns
the first column that i want to show you
is the user id column
the user id column tells us which user
the game data was collected from
now there are 14 columns the game
completed data tells us the date and
time of game completion
the team tells us if the player is an
imposter or a crew mate
the outcome
tells us if the game was won or lost
so over here this is each game that a
certain user has played user id is used
to represent the user who has played the
game and as you can see we've collected
data from 29 different people
and the number of games that these 29
people
totally have played is over 2000
the outcome tells us whether the
user has won or lost in this game the
task completed tells us how many tasks
was completed by this user in this game
all tasks completed tells us when the
user was able to finish their tasks
murder tells us if the user was murdered
and imposter kills
tells us the number of kills by the
imposter
so if the user was not an impostor we do
not have data on how many kills was
committed by the impostor during that
particular game that's why this column
has a lot of missing values
gamelan tells us
the total duration of the game and
ejected tells us if the player was
ejected or thrown off of the spaceship
by their fellow players
sabotage is fixed is basically
the imposter within the game can create
sabotages and it's the crewmates duty to
fix them
so this tells us the number of sabotages
which was fixed by this particular
crewmate
time to complete all tasks tells us the
duration taken by the crewmates to
complete all the tasks and the rank
change tells us the change in rank after
wins or losses of the game
the region
or the game code tells us the server and
the game code
now first let's just see how exactly the
data is distributed
so this tells us how many
uh counts each column has
so as you can see here most of them have
the same number of counts except rank
change which has a couple of missing
values
unique tells us how many unique values
exist
in each column
so obviously team there will be two
because there are only two possible
outcomes you can either be a crewmate or
you can either be an imposter outcome
also has only two unique values because
you either win a game or you lose a game
task completed has 12 different values
and this is because the
number of tasks which have been
completed probably range from 1 to 12.
all tasks completed has three values
which is yes no and missing data and the
same goes for murdered you have yes no
or missing data
impostor kills tells us how many kills
the imposter has made
so
in this case
uh the most skills that the person has
made is probably nine
uh game length there are 988 different
values and ejected again there are only
two values because you can either be
ejected or you can either stay in the
game
now the top value tells us the most
frequently occurring value and the
frequency tells us the frequencies of
all of the top values
now let's create a feature called minute
and extract data from game length
so we're going to be splitting the game
length column which is this column and
we're going to be converting it into
minutes
and then we're going to be
using that data and creating a separate
feature column called minutes
out of it
so let's do this
so these are the first top two values of
our minutes call of our new minutes
column
uh the zeroth value is seven because the
first
game length that you see here was of
seven minutes so all that we're doing is
that we're going to be splitting this
value which is seven minutes four
seconds and we're gonna be keeping only
the first value which is that of the
minutes
the second minutes value is 16 minutes
and that corresponds to the second value
in our minutes feature
variable
now
let's take a look at the murdered column
the modded column has yes no yes no
values and missing data set and missing
values
so let's change those we're gonna be
replacing no values with not murdered
yes values with murdered
and the simple dash with missing
and we're gonna be doing this in place
which basically means that this is going
to make a change to our main data frame
so this is done let's take a look at a
data frame now
this is what our data frame looks like
we have a game's length column we have a
minutes column
and we also have made changes to our
murdered column which is represented
here so now we don't have any missing
values or dashes in our murdered column
we have all of it represented as
categorical data
and this is one of the main columns that
we're going to be using to plot our pi
plots
so now let's see how we can plot a pie
chart
the first thing that we're going to be
doing is that we're going to be
getting the total value counts
in our team column here
so we're going to be plotting a pie
chart with the help of this team column
and we're going to be getting the value
counts of each unique
value in the team column
so let's
you can do this with the help of the
value counts function
that pandas data frames provides us with
announce that we have the value counts
of each unique value which is present in
our team column let's plot it in the
form of a pie chart
we're gonna be doing this with the help
of the plot bokeh function
and the type of chart that we want to
plot is a pie chart
let's give it the title
as
ratio of
imposters
versus
chromates
and let's run this now
and this is what your pi plot looks like
after you've plotted it
so now the same thing can be done to
plot a donut plot
the first thing that we want to see is
if there are more crewmates or imposters
murdered or not in the game
to do this we will add two more features
angle and color which are going to be
used in the chart
so to
get angle we're going to be importing pi
from math
and we're going to be converting our
angle in the form of radians
and as for the color feature we're going
to be having three different shades of
blue
so this is basically what our
murder data frame looks like
uh so over here you have not murdered
the total value counts of which
is 894 and the angle that this gives us
is 2.5
22302 and this is the corresponding
color the same goes for murdered which
is 867 values and we've converted that
into an angle in radians and given it
its own color and finally we also have
missing values
of which there are 466 the angle is
1.314756 and it has its own
corresponding color
so this is the data frame that we're
going to be using to plot our donor
chart
so from bokeh dot transform we import
cumulative sum
and the cumulative sum is what we're
going to be using to find the start of
our angle or basically to find
or basically to find how much portion of
our donor chart is going to be occupied
by the angle
so the donut chart can be plotted using
the angular wedge function from figure
so the x axis here is 0 and the y axis
is 1 the inner radius is the radius that
you are going to be giving to the inner
smaller circle and that we've given us
0.15 the outer radius is the radius of
the bigger outer circle
and the direction in which our data is
going to be plotted is in the
anti-clockwise direction
so let's run this
and this is what our donut chart looks
like
so the not murdered
is this dark blue color portion of our
donut chart and when you hold
and when you hover over it you can see
how many values are present in the not
murdered column
the same goes for murdered and because
we've plotted our data in the
anti-clockwise function
this is how it's being plotted so
murdered not murdered and then finally
you have the missing values
the way that you can interpret this
graph is that you can say that most of
the people were murdered during the game
but most of the data is missing so we
can't say for certain whether the
majority of the people were murdered
during the game or not because the
number of missing values can make a huge
difference and the number of people who
are not murdered and the number of
people who are murdered are very close
to each other like their total values
are very close to each other
next we will create a data frame of
sabotages fixed and minutes and change
the column name and add t in them
so this is basically what we're doing
we've created a data frame which has the
number of sabotages fixed and the
minutes
now let's just take the three sabotages
which were fixed which is 0 1 and 2 and
create a data frame out of all of these
so each of these individual data frames
just contains these individual columns
to make a simple scatter plot with only
one legend we can pass the data and use
scatter to make the charts
so basically we're just plotting the
scatter chart in bokeh here
and this is what our minutes
scatter chart looks like
now we're plotting this for one t we're
plotting the minute at which one
sabotage was fixed
and another cool thing about bokeh
charts is that you can always zoom into
them or zoom out of them to better see
where your data is plotted
so this is a scatter chart which has
only one variable which is one t and the
minute at which it was plotted
to make a scatter chart with more
variables we are going to need to use
circle
which is a method of figure object which
we've already seen before
the circle is one of the many plotting
styles which are provided by bokeh you
can also use triangles or many more you
don't have to make each point a circle
so we're gonna be plotting
so we're gonna be plotting the sabotage
is fixed and the minute at which they
were fixed
and we're gonna be plotting three
different circles of three different
colors
i mean each of them correspond to how
many sabotages were fixed at what time
zero sabotages at what time one sabotage
at what time and two at what time so
let's run this
so as you can see here
when zero sabotages were fixed these
were the times
when one was fixed this was the time at
which it was fixed and when 2 was fixed
this is the time that it was fixed at
now the x-axis is our minutes and the
y-axis is the sabotage
when you hover over it you can see
various information about where each uh
circle is plotted
so this has an index of 10
the data x y will tell you the
exact
x coordinate and the y coordinate and
the screen x y will tell you the screen
pixels on which it is plotted
so now we've taken a look at pie charts
let's move on to histograms
so what exactly is a histogram
histograms are used to plot numerical
data according to the range that they
fall into the data is plotted in the
form of bins or rectangles and the
y-axis corresponds to the amount of data
present in a certain range or at a
certain point
so this is what a histogram looks like
this is a histogram of the distribution
of minutes
so the x-axis has the range
within which this data falls like over
here the first range is from 0 to 2.9
and second one is from 2.9 to 5.8
each range
has a
value of 2.9
and the corresponding y-axis or the
height of the bins
tells us how much data is present within
this range
so this is how you can read histograms
now let's see how we can plot them using
python bouquet
now let's see the distribution of
minutes in the among us game we will use
his to plot a histogram
basically just going to be plotting the
minutes of our game
uh we're going to be using the df min
column for this
and we're going to be converting it
into
an integer
so this is the column that we're going
to be plotting let's plot this
again we're going to be using the plot
bokeh
function here
because it makes plotting data frames
very easy
the kind of data frame that we're going
to be using is the histogram or hist
and the title of our
graph is going to be
distribution
of
minutes so let's run this
now this is what our histogram looks
like
now this is when we've only plotted one
variable which is minutes
yeah so another thing that you can plot
is a stacked histogram
a start histogram is when you plot
various histograms on top of each other
so let's see how this works
for a start histogram we want to see if
the game length has a correlation with
the amount of imposters and crewmates in
our game
so to do this we're going to be creating
a small data frame which has the game
length and the team columns combined
so
let's do that
this
and this is what this looks like
so all you have to do to plot this in
the form of a stacked histogram is use
the hist function again
so
let's see how that is done
and let's give this figure a size of
say
[Music]
750
comma
350
so so let's run this again and this is
the start histogram that you get
we have two different columns which are
plotted on top of each other
uh versus the game length
so basically this tells us that when the
game length was between
0 to 0.9 minutes the
number of imposters
was way higher than the number of
crewmates
and the longer the game went on the
number of imposters decreased and the
number of crewmates just kept getting
longer and longer
now obviously you can say that the
number of crewmates is decreasing as the
game goes on too but this is because the
imposters would have killed off most of
the crewmates
as you can see here towards the end
there are no imposters which means that
most of the imposters were rejected and
the crewmates won
so now we've taken a look at histograms
let's move on to bar plots and
understand how exactly they're different
from histograms
so
in histograms you have plotted numerical
data distributions as of yet
in bar plots you plot for categorical
data
it also uses bins to plot the amount of
data when the bins are stored stacked on
top of each other it's called a stack
bar chart this is basically what a bar
chart looks like the difference is this
does not have its own range
each bar is used to represent a
categorical data and the height is used
to tell us how much of that categorical
data is present
so now let's see how we can plot a bar
plot
so again we're gonna be making a small
data frame of the task completed and the
value counts of how many tasks have been
completed
to plot a bar plot we're gonna be using
plot bokeh again and the kind of plot
that we want to plot is bar
so let's run this and see what we get
so here is your bar plot
the task completed in this case is
categorical data
and the counts basically tells us how
many value counts fall into each
category
so zero does completed are 69
one task completed is 117.
task completed is 10
and so on
uh from this bar chart you can say that
the most number of tasks completed is 7
and the least task completed are 10.
now let's create a start bar chart and
let's see who wins imposters or
crewmates
to create a start bar chart what we're
going to be doing is that we're going to
be creating a different smaller data
frame of team and outcome
to make sure that the bar chart is
stacked all you have to do is include a
start attribute in your bar function and
change its value to true
so let's run this and see
and here you can see that we have a
stacked bar chart
so you can see that crewmates who have a
lot more data
have
won
981 times and lost 780 times
while imposters have lost
205 times and one 216 times
so the crewmates have one significantly
far more than the number of times
imposters have won
now let's take a look at stacked
vertical bar charts so so far the bar
charts that we've been looking at have
been horizontal which means
that the data
goes upwards
for a vertical bar chart we're going to
be seeing if all tasks have been
completed or not
so
in the data frame column all tasks
completed we're gonna be replacing the
values of yes and no with task completed
and task not completed
we're also gonna be creating
a smaller data frame of the outcome
column and the task completed column
to plot a start vertical bar chart you
are going to be using
python bokeh dot bar h function and
you're going to be crea
changing the stat
attribute to true
this is what a stacked horizontal bar
chart looks like
so over here we can see that the missing
values is represented by blue task
completed by orange and task not
completed by green
here you can see the total outcome you
can see how many wins how many tasks are
completed and how many tasks are not yet
completed
and the same goes for losses you can see
how many losses have occurred how many
tasks are completed and how many tasks
were not completed this is a very good
way of representing a lot of data in a
relatively smaller area
now
the way we can interpret this graph is
that we can say that finishing the task
will automatically
ensure that the crewmates have one so
there's a higher number of people who
need to complete the task to win the
game
another very unique type of bar chart
that you can have is a bi-directional
bar chart
so let's plot a bi-directional
bar chart in which the bars will be
going both ways to the left and to the
right
we're gonna be plotting
a horizontal bar chart over here
to make it easier for you to see
to have
a bidirectional bar chart you need
positive values and negative values the
center
is going to be at zero
so here we're going to be making the
loss features negative by multiplying
the loss feature with the minus one
value
so here we go the losses are all
negatives and the wins are all positives
right now let's run this
and see
how many losses and wins have occurred
for each user
so user one
has 42 losses
and 58 wins but you can easily see
whether they have one more or less or
lost more by comparing the height of the
bars
for the wins and the losses
so we can easily say that in this
scenario user 1 has one more times than
they have lost
the same can be said for user 2 where
the
wins bar is significantly higher than
the losses bar
so this is how you can
plot and understand a bi-directional bar
chart so we've taken a look at how we
can plot bar charts and the various
types of bar charts that are available
to us in python bouquet
now let's take a look at area plots
area plots is a combination of the line
and the bar chart when the area below a
line is shaded
using an area chart we can see how the
values of different groups change over a
period of time
the area chart has different baselines
to show the vertical range of data
here we've
plotted the sabotages fixed versus the
minutes at which they were fixed at
right so these are the minutes and the
sabotage is fixed
are of two types zero t and one t
so the number of minutes that we're
considering here is somewhere around 28
ish right and zero t as you can see has
a way higher value
so one really good thing about area
plots especially in this case is that
they have two ranges
and they have another range on the y
axis which is which tells us how the
number of sabotages fixed is ranging
so zero sabotage is fixed you can see
how the value keeps fluctuating
and
how the value changes for different
minutes
and the same can be said for one t
now one t has a baseline which is over
here which is just above the zero t
baseline this doesn't necessarily mean
that this is where
one t starts and this is where it ends
this just means that it ranges
from zero all the way here and we can
compare
very easily how zero sabotage is fixed
and one sabotage is fixed range or
change with respect to each other
at
the same time
now the first thing that we're going to
be doing to plot our area chart is that
we're going to be creating
another data frame this is called df
minutes which is going to be comprising
of the minutes column of our data frame
and the sabotage's fixed column of the
same data frame
for df min we're going to be renaming
the columns to 0t and
1t and the only columns that we're going
to be
considering out of the five different
columns that we have are the zero t and
the one t column
we're going to be combining all of these
together in a format which can be
plotted
by using bokeh and column data source
helps us do this it helps us convert
our various
data frame columns into lists
next we're going to be using the figure
function and we're going to give our
figure a width of 400 a height of 400
and the title of sabotage is fixed
versus the minutes at which they were
fixed at
to plot a start area graph you're going
to be using v area underscore stack
function
from the figure module
you're going to be passing in your y
parameters which is y naught and y one
because we have two different y
parameters here and the x parameter
which is df minutes
the color that you're gonna be using is
gray and light gray
the legend labels are the names that
you've already put here which is 0t and
1t
and the source of your data is going to
be this column data source
now let's run this and see how our area
chart looks
so this is our area chart we've got in
two different sabotages here and two
different times
at which they occur which is zero t and
one t
the minutes tells us how many sabotages
were fixed at each time
basically how long it took to fix a
sabotage and the minute during the game
at which they occurred
now let's take a look
at the layout function of our bokeh
library
the layout function will let us build a
grid of plots and wedges we can have as
many rows and columns or grids of plots
in one layout
using the layout function we can see
various graphs at the exact same time
mainly used for designing dashboards it
lets you build grids of plots
so this is basically what your layout
function
will help you do
this is going to look very good in a
website because it's going to arrange
our plots in a way that we can easily
see all of them
and understand all of them without any
loss of data
this is also arranged very neatly which
is exactly what the layout functions
allow us to do
so now let's take a look at how the
layout function can be implemented in
python bokeh
now of the layout functions there are
many different layout options which are
available
you have the column function which
allows you to display
plots vertically
and you have the grid function which
lets you display plots in the form of
grids
now for example um
let's say that we want to make a
dashboard layout in bokeh
uh we are going to be considering
three different charts
the first one that we're gonna be
considering is a lollipop chart which is
done here
the next one that we're gonna be
considering are two pie charts
so this is how you plot a lollipop chart
and i'll show you what exactly a
lollipop chart is in just a minute
the first thing that you need to know is
that the first graph that we're going to
be plotting
is going to be a graph which has the
user id versus the outcome of the games
plotted
on it
so what we're going to be doing here is
that we're going to be creating a single
data frame which has
all of the
user ids
present in it along with the user
and the wins that the user has obtained
now using this we're going to be
plotting it in the form of
a plot in decreasing order where we have
the top 10 users who have one
which basically means that the users who
have won the most number of games out of
all the users in consideration
so figure one segment will basically
help you plot
a line which has a width of two and a
circle will be at the circle at the very
top of this segment so lollipop chart is
going to be
a horizontal line with a circle at the
very top
so the next graph that we're going to be
plotting is going to be a murdered
and not murdered and missing values pie
chart
and the last thing that we're going to
be plotting is a donut chart of the
teams
and the values within them
so these are the three different graphs
that we're going to be plotting and
these are just us creating the graphs
and plotting them
the main logic is over here
the main logic is that you want to set a
layout in bokeh
as to how you want to see the charts
so the layout that we are going to be
looking at is that we're going to be
having a lollipop chart at the very top
and two smaller pie charts at the bottom
right
so
we have three figures here
and the first thing that we're going to
be doing is that we're going to be
giving these
figures
a line color of none
the axis is not going to be visible and
the axis labels are not present for
these figures
this is the main function that you're
going to be looking at this is your
layout using the grade layout function
that you've imported here from python
from bokeh dot layouts you're going to
be creating a grid
and how does the grid know where the
figures are
so you've divided the grid into two this
is evident because you have two figures
two main figures here
which are separated by a comma so this
tells the grid that the page is going to
be divided into two
the first figure which is on top is
going to be figure one and the figure at
the bottom are figure 2 and 3
this means that the bottom half is going
to be further split into
vertically
let's run this and see what our layout
looks like so here you have it your
entire page is divided into two
the first one has one the figure one
which is the lollipop chart and the
bottom half of our page
has two figures which are the two donut
charts
the bottom half is divided exactly into
two as you can see here
this is because that is the grid layout
that we wanted
so this is how you can use the layout
function in
python bokeh it is extremely easy all
you have to do is create a layout by
using the grid function or you can also
use the column function the column
function will
plot it
in the form of a single column
vertically
using the grid function you can plot
figures vertically as shown here
so when you separate them by commas with
respect to each other they will be plot
but they will be plotted vertically and
when you group them together
and separate them with commas internally
they will be plotted horizontally
so now we've taken a look at how we can
use the layout function
now let's see how we can make
interactive graphs with the help of
bokeh
over here we're going to be using bokeh
to design a dashboard which is used to
represent the horsepower in cars
we are also going to make our graphs
interactive and see how maximum
information can be conveyed with the
help of a single graph
so here we have multiple different cars
and along with the cars will also be
going to be given their horse bars
a little bit of other information about
them and their images
and over here as you can see
we have a very simple
vertical bar chart
but let's see how we can make it
interactive and convey all the
information that we have in our single
data set on this one bar graph
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of our
important necessary modules we're
obviously going to have the pandas
modules which is going to be imported to
work with the data frame that we've
given
apart from this we're also going to be
importing
figures output file show save and column
data source from bokeh.plotting we
already know that the figure function is
used to plot different types of graphs
which are given
output file is just used to see our file
the show is used to display our graphs
and save will help you save your graph
now the column data source is the core
of most bokeh plots
it provides the data to the glyph of
your plot when you pass sequences like
python lists or numpy arrays to a bokeh
render bokeh automatically creates a
column data source with this data for
you so this is basically what you're
going to be using to pass data onto your
bokeh glyphs
apart from this we're also going to be
using a harvard tool function
and
a trans and from the
transform function we're going to be
importing factor c map
we're going to be importing a palette
color
which is going to be various shades of
blue
and we're going to be importing
components from the embedded function of
bokeh
let's just see how we can use all of
these and the different things that they
do
the first thing that you're going to be
doing is reading in your car's data
frame and creating a column data source
so that you can easily pass this data
onto your
bokeh glyphs
so let's run
and import all of our various required
functionalities and import the data as
well
so this is what your data set looks like
we have eight different values in our
data set which are the names of
different cars their horsepower their
price and a hyperlink of an image
this is what our data set looks like we
have only eight columns
so using this data set we're going to be
plotting a horizontal bar graph
again we're going to be
calling our figure function and we're
going to be giving y range to our car
list
the y range is basically just going to
have the different values which are
going to be present on the y axis we've
given the blot a width of 800 and a
height of 600
the title of the plot is cars with top
horsepower and the x-axis label is
horsepower
the tools that we're using here is pan
box select zoom in zoom out save and
reset so these are tools that you're
going to be getting on the right side of
your plot
now let's render our glyph or render our
graph
the graph that we are going to be using
here is the horizontal bar graph so the
y axis is going to have cars
and the right or basically the height of
the entire bar is going to depend on the
horsepower
the left is going to start from 0 and
the height of each bar is going to be
0.4
the color that we are going to be giving
is going to be a palette of blue so each
different car will have a different
color of blue associated with it and
the
color of blue which is associated with
it will depend on the car list
now fill alpha 0.9 the source is your
source data that you have over here
which is the column data source of our
data frame
and the legend is going to be car which
basically means that your entire uh
plot is going to have the legend of car
now we're gonna be adding the legend
this is
us giving the legend its orientation so
the legend is going to be vertically
oriented the location is going to be on
the top right and the font size of the
text car of a legend is going to be 10
px or 10 pixels
we're also going to be adding a hover
tool
inside this harvard tool this hover tool
tips will basically tell you what you're
going to be seeing
in the harvard toolbox
so we're going to be creating this with
the help of an html format
the first thing that you're going to be
seeing is the name of the car
the next
column will have the price of the car
the horsepower of the car
and the image
now the image is in the form of a
hyperlink and this is going to be auto
populated in your hover tool
the width of the image is going to be
800
so
we are going to add all of these hover
tools to our p image and we are finally
going to be showing you the graph and
what it looks like
so this is your bouquet plot here the
name the title of the plot is cars with
top horsepower this is your
legend which is cars
the name of each car is given here along
with the color which is associated with
it here are the different tools that we
have
you can save this
you can reset it you can zoom out you
can zoom in
you can select the boxes
and you can pan your image
so here we're zooming in here we're
zooming out
if we save this the plot automatically
gets
downloaded in your system and if you
reset it the image goes back to exactly
what it looked like when it was first
opened
now
here you have the names of the different
cars on the y-axis and you have the
various horse bars on the x-axis
let's take a look at a harvard tool
so here you have the name of the car
which is on top you have the price and
you have the horse bar and as you can
see you have the image which is hyper
pop which is populated instantly from
the hyperlink that was available to us
now the color palette associated with
each car
gets darker the more the horsepower of
the car increases
so here we have cars with top
horsepowers
which are arranged in an
ascending order from the top and a
descending order from the bottom
so this is another way that you can use
bokeh to create extremely interactive
and informational graphs
here in just half a page
and this is us making a huge plot right
we can also decrease the size of the
plot if you want to
but basically in half a page we've
conveyed all the information
ranging from the name of the car to its
model to the horsepower that is ha that
it has its price and also its image
and this is also very good way to
compare it
so these are just some functionalities
which are provided in bokeh itself no
other
data visualization library will let you
work so well
with graphs and will let you customize
your graphs to this extent
thank you all for watching this video on
the python data visualization tutorial i
hope you liked it if you have any
questions please feel free to put them
in the comment section thank you again
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here